ja sicherlich und bei herrn bosbach ist
herr bosbach rosberg sie ein erfahrener
politiker auch und deswegen ist das
natürlich auch klar
und deswegen ist die cdu auch sehr
erfolgreich weil die muster bei ihm
natürlich auf alle übertragbar sind wenn
der gegner gewonnen hat dann hat das
ganze gewonnen und man darf das nicht
dem gegner zu schreiben diesen gewinnen
diese diese metaphern sagen wir so
kennen wir legitim ist das aber sofern
muss man sagen gaben alle an einem
strang gezogen sowohl cdu als auch csu
und auch die spd liegen dabei wolfgang
borst war
deutschland hat zumindest auf dem papier
gewonnen ob deutschland wirklich gewählt
wie sage es noch einmal an der exekution
der maßnahmen also das durchzusetzen und
das wird die schwierigkeit und da werden
wir sehen ob das was auf dem papier
steht auch tatsächlich das hält was es
noch fest bist